With our previous discussion
of the classes, P and
NP in mind,
you can visualize the classes like this.
Clearly P is contained inside of NP.
And we're pretty sure that
this containment is strict.
That is to say there are some
problems in NP but not in P.
Where the answer can be
verified efficiently, but
it can't be found efficiently.
But no one knows how to prove this yet.
In this picture then, you can imagine
the harder problems being at the top.
Now, suppose for
a moment that you encounter some problem
where you know how to verify the answer
but where you think that finding
an answer is intractable.
Unfortunately, you boss or maybe your
advisor doesn't agree with you, and
keeps asking for an efficient solution.
How would you go about showing that
the problem is, in fact, intractable?
One idea is to show that
the problem is not in P.
That would indeed show that it is not
intractable, but it would do much more.
It would show that P is not equal to NP.
You would be famous.
As we talked about in the last lecture,
whether P is equal to NP is one of
the great open questions in mathematics.
So I'm going to cross that out.
I don't want to discourage you
from trying to prove this theorem
necessarily.
You should just know
what you're getting into.
Another option is to reduce another
intractable problem to your problem.
If you were working in the early or
mid-1970s,
you might have reduced linear
programming to your problem.
Practical methods for solving some
linear programs were available, but
most people thought that in general
it was not polynomially solvable.
Since the solution to your problem
would solve any linear program
your problem must be harder.
The trouble with this approach is
that it was later shown that linear
programming actually was
polynomially solvable.
Hence the fact that your problem
is as hard as linear programming
doesn't mean much anymore.
The Class P swallowed
linear programming.
Why couldn't it swallow your program,
as well?
This type of argument isn't worthless,
but
it's not as convincing as it might be.
It would be much better
to reduce your problem
to a problem that we knew was
one of the hardest in NP.
So hard that if P were to swallow it,
it would've had to have
swallowed all of NP.
In other words,
it would have to move this line
here all the way up to the top.
Such a problem would
have to be NP complete.
Meaning that we can reduce
every language in NP to it.
Remarkable as it may seem, it turns
out there are lots of such languages,
satisfiability being the first one for
which this was proved.
In other words, we know that it has
to be at the top of this image.
Turning back to how to show that
your problem is intractable.
Short of proving that P is not equal
to NP, the best we can do is reduce
an NP-complete problem
like SAT to your problem.
Then your problem would
also be NP-complete and
the only way that your problem could
be polynomially solvable is if
this line moves up here and everything
in NP Is polynomially solvable.
There are two parts to this argument.
The first is the idea of
a polynomial reduction.
We've seen reductions before in
the context of computability.
Here, are the reductions we not
only have to be computable, but
to be computable in polynomial time.
This idea will occupy
the first half of the lesson.
The second half, we'll consider
this idea of NP completeness and
we'll go over the famous
Cook-Levin theorem.
Which showed that bouillon
satisfiability is NP-complete